hey dr. Berg here in this video I'm
going to talk about right shoulder pain
now many of you have this right muscle
thing right here that just irritates the
heck out of you and you go home and your
spouse massage that thing you go to
massage therapist and you're working on
this muscle you go to the chiropractor
get it adjusted and it keeps coming back
it's on the right side it's this little
ropey tight muscle right up by the
scapula right here the name of that
muscle is called the levator or angle
ass gap of the muscle so it pulls this
little bone up here in the shoulder and
sometimes you might have pain at this
rhomboid right next to the scapula right
here and that's a very common thing and
I want to show you what's really behind
that it's actually something called
referred pain it's not coming from this
area at all it's coming from something
called your gallbladder and your liver
because that's right behind it and
there's a little nerve that goes right
through there let me show you okay so
check this out
we have the little liver right here the
liver is about right here it's about the
size of a football about three pounds
it's huge and then it has a little tube
that connects to this gallbladder right
and the gallbladder is there to hold and
release something called bile B I I'll
eat that helps you digest fatty foods it
helps you do a lot of things and extract
nutrients from fat especially the fat
Seibel vitamins vitamin A D e ke that
type of thing so what happens what's
really going on with this right neck
thing it's being referred by the
gallbladder now some of you might say
well I don't I've never been diagnosed
with the gallbladder problem I don't
have stones but stones are the last
thing that occur after gallbladder liver
dysfunction this has it just starts in a
sequence of little small things that
build up over time I think that's the
problem with going to the doctor he'll
it'll say well come back in six months
when you have the problem and then we'll
properly remove your gallbladder they're
not doing anything actively right now to
save the gallbladder the gallbladder
gets beaten up by junk foods
by alcohol by eating breads and pastas
and serving on crackers so it's really
the crap that we're eating that messes
this gallbladder up and you know I have
people all day long that come in that
say well when can I go back to drinking
alcohol or when can I go back to eating
real foods well just as long as you want
a healthy liver I mean unfortunately
when you take away things like alcohol
or junk food a lot of things come up and
I think people don't even realize how
addicted they are to those things
especially even alcohol I had a guy a
couple weeks ago who you know he says I
have a craving for alcohol come to find
out he does it almost every single night
and so he starts the program and I
probably shouldn't have taken a mom
because that so-called craving was
really an addiction an addiction is
something you cannot give up and you're
doing excessively and so it's
interesting I found out after he came in
the next day
he went back to drinking the next day he
drank over the weekend he drank the next
day and then he was complaining that the
program didn't work and he told me he
was drinking so and the interesting
thing that happens when patients cheat
on their diet or they go off the program
they have to justify it in their mind
and so what they have to do is they have
to basically become very critical and so
he went on social media had made some
comments about me whatever but the truth
is that he went off the program programs
not going to work so you have to justify
it by making credit criticizing someone
else so that's what really happened but
the key is that alcohol does mess up the
liver and the gallbladder but it needs
certain things to help repair it and
probably one of the best things to help
repair a gallbladder and liver would be
things like bitter cruciferous
vegetables at the top of the list the
best thing for the liver would be beet
tops so if you were to buy beets at the
grocery store a farmers market and cut
off those beet tops and cut those up and
put those in your salad or in your case
oh my gosh that would be the best thing
for the gallbladder and liver because
it'll start to rebuild that thing back
up but you're going to have to come off
that alcohol if you have a congested
gallbladder especially if you have this
so now how do you know it's getting
better well this is a really good kind
of an indicator to know your livers and
your gallbladder is doing better by how
this feels if this does better than we
know it's better it still hurts then
there's still a problem with this so you
might have to you know really work on
this over time the liver is probably one
of the only organs that can completely
regenerate a hundred percent if you give
it time and so I did have another guy
call me up and says well dr. Berg your
program doesn't work because I did it
and as soon as I went back to my normal
eating the problem came back I was like
really I said you did it for two weeks
you got to do this thing for a lot
longer it takes up to three years of
healthy eating to repair the liver and I
think that's some people don't
understand how long it takes like if you
have osteoporosis like your bones are
completely thin and you start taking
calcium for a few weeks you're not going
to see any change it takes years of
building back up those minerals because
osteoporosis is a very serious serious
mineral deficiency and other
deficiencies as well
well the liver takes years to build up -
and that thing takes years to come back
just because it doesn't show up on a
blood test does it mean that your liver
is healthy you have to basically have 90
percent of your liver to be
dysfunctional before you even notice any
symptoms on a blood test so it can be
completely fatty and you're feeling fine
sort of speak so you really have to kind
of eat healthy now and prevent issues I
mean there's never a week that goes by
that someone says yeah my friend just
got cancer she had no symptoms and she
has cancer now she has to go through
chemo I don't want to wake up one day
and have cancer I want to wake up and
have a stroke
I want to actively aggressively get my
body healthy every day to prevent and
avoid all these issues but this Galba
and liver is one of the best indicators
is the whole right shoulder neck thing
so you really want to get your
lifestyle in a place where find other
pleasures you know other than junk food
in alcohol now can you ever drink
alcohol again well why don't you just
get the liver healthy and then see what
you can get away with down the road but
first let's focus on creating health so
this is the real cause to a lot of right
shoulder stuff and if that thing is
really messed up it can even cause so
much tension up there it can cause the
vertebra to rotate out and cause bones
to even literally go out of place and
cause nerve pain down the shoulder the
whole thing but the point is I
personally had this problem for about 12
years I didn't know what it was until I
started to take care of my liver and oh
my gosh it was I thought it was an
injury because I was right-sided I was a
tennis player I was wrestler yes I had
those injuries but this was really
behind the situation so what is the
bottom line the bottom line is take care
of your liver and your gallbladder and
listen to your body listen to what it
tells you don't ignore it and understand
what certain things mean this muscle
thing right here means gallbladder okay
so in addition to consuming bitter
vegetables you may want to try a remedy
I have it's called a gall bladder
formula I developed this basically for
myself my liver it's not just for the
gallbladder though it has three main
ingredients one is a purified bowel self
to give you more bile to help dissolve
that crud that's in the gallbladder to
prevent stones absorb nutrients vitamin
A D E K 1 K 2 so those are all key
nutrients that you need for a nutrient
absorption but it also has an acidified
for the stomach because in order to
release the bile the stomach needs to be
really really acid so this has betaine
hydrochloride to help your own body make
more bile from the stomach level and
also it has pancreatic enzymes to help
the pancreas dissolve nutrients to what
one indications that you need pancreas
enzymes is that if you eliminate food
through the waste and it doesn't digest
like you might see undigested food and
your waste
then it's really a pancreas problem so
it has all three elements for the
stomach
gallbladder pancreas but it also has in
here stone root if there's a stone in
the gallbladder it has things to thin
the bile so it's really good for
bloating and I might just take one as
the maintenance for breakfast some
people if it's real bad they might take
one with each meal but basically you
just take start with taking one for
breakfast and you just take it right
before you eat and then you'll notice
that your digestion you don't you'll
feel more satisfied when you eat you
won't crave sweets after eating you'll
feel less bloated and this big ropey
thing will start going down down down
but this doesn't give you the permission
to start drinking and eating junk but it
allows you to get some relief as you're
cleaning up your diet so you may want to
check it out and try it so thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
video